for many people training is treated like
punishment a punishment for eating too
much for getting out of shape for being
lazy in the evenings for not being good
enough
this is just a form of self-flagellation
at worst the best amounts to a chore
something you need to do a few times a
week but absolutely do not want to do
just like washing the dishes eating
vegetables topping up your petrol and
that attitude can bleed out of the gym
too as we never give ourselves
permission to relax or to eat something
we enjoy is there any wonder that most
people don't eagerly look forward to
their training when this is their
psychological approach to it it's a
surprise that we struggle with
motivation and adherence to a program
this doesn't strike me as terribly
healthy either and it's mad because it
seems like this is precisely what a lot
of influencers seem to be preaching as
ideal wearing just how miserable their
training makes them like a badge of
honor
and again is that super healthy and does
it need to be that way for me it's quite
the opposite for me training is a form
of self-expression it is love for life
and for your body and it's really fun
thing is once you start taking an
approach to training that is a little
bit more like this you'll often find
it's much easier and more fun to stick
to a program often you'll actually get
better results you'll be less stressed
you'll have a healthier relationship
with your body and with food and you'll
even reduce your risk of injury because
you won't be pushing yourself to insane
levels all the time so here's a good
start instead of thinking of all the
things you don't like about yourself
instead of training to fix things or to
get rid of things instead think about
what you want to be think about what you
want to be able to do that way we're at
least focusing on something positive
instead of something negative but even
this still falls short of truly
embracing the joy of training we know
that simply working towards a reward is
enough to kill the fun in pretty much
anything the quickest way to lose your
love of something is to get paid for it
or to study it formally
so really we want to enjoy training as
an end not just as a means don't get me
wrong there are loads of really good
reasons to set goals and work towards
them but how about you try training
without a goal just for a few weeks see
what you gravitate towards see what you
actually enjoy doing because here's the
thing there's no requirement for you to
do anything specific in the gym don't
like squatting don't do it think outside
the box and explore your options there's
loads out there you might find you take
to powerlifting or you might discover
that you have a love for hand balancing
and calisthenics and it doesn't need to
fit the usual definition of training
either if you love football then playing
lots of football will get you fitter
than a lot of people and you'll have fun
doing it rock climbing is amazingly good
for you so martial arts so is swimming
dance is insanely beneficial better yet
pick a few of these and you'll be
absolutely golden you don't need to do
strength training or running in a
conventional fashion if you don't want
to more on all this in a future video
so there are no rules no one is in
charge you're not in competition with
anyone just enjoy moving and expressing
your physicality in a way that's
authentic to you thing is you'll find a
style of movement and of strength that
suits you and it will be unique to you
of course it's important that we
maintain a basic level of Health if you
want to age gracefully play with our
kids and feel good about ourselves but
of course it's your body man
but all we need to do to meet this basic
criteria is to move often and in a
variety of ways that's it and this once
again is where a lot of the narrative on
YouTube seems to get a little warped to
me people talk about strength training
like it's an obligation or running
whatever their flavor of training is but
as I've explained on this channel many
times you're likely already strong
enough for your everyday tasks and if
you move regularly you'll maintain basic
stability core strength and Mobility
anything on top of that is optional and
it's maddening when people talk about
gym culture like it's not just a bit of
fun like it's this life and death
mandate from the heavens I train because
I want to be like Batman or Jackie Chan
or Arnie and Stallone that's pretty
nerdy and I own it but I also suspect
that a lot of those other very serious
people are actually just playing as well
if you're training like the military but
you're not actually in the military then
guess what you're playing and if you
want to get massively muscular then
surely on some level you're inspired by
either a movie or something equally
silly
foreign
as pretending to be Batman pretending to
be Bruce Wayne and that means looking
and feeling smart to this end I highly
recommend today's sponsor Harry's
Harry's is a razor brand that takes
Personal Care seriously they create high
quality razors with super sharp blades
and quality weighted handles it's all
packaged beautifully and they also make
a really smooth and refreshing shaving
gel with aloe I'm actually someone who
struggles with shaving I have like baggy
skin or something so I'm constantly
cutting myself or missing hairs I've
genuinely found Harry's to offer one of
the best shaving experiences and it's
very clear that the company puts real
care into their product and again this
is Apparent from the packaging alone
which you can see me digging into here
so if you want to try Harry's out for
yourself then just visit my link in the
description below you'll get the starter
set which includes a five blade German
engineered razor cartridge weighted
textured handle shave gel with aloe and
travel blade cover for a fraction of the
usual 13 price us audiences will get
their starter sets for just three
dollars or three pounds and 95 Pence for
UK audiences
thanks once again to Harry's for
sponsoring this video and now on with
the show
as children we play intuitively
psychologists are generally in agreement
that play is training for later life so
by the same token then training must be
play the gym is a playground
so can we all just lighten up about it
when people start savagely arguing about
whether powerlifting is better or
bodybuilding they might as well be
arguing which is the best Power Ranger I
never liked Power Rangers I was a
Transformers Guy this is true of martial
arts too people get so up in arms
shouting about fake martial arts and
what has and hasn't been tested guess
what no martial art works when you're in
the street and jumped by five guys with
knives or guns when I got attacked I was
also extremely drunk martial arts are
amazing for you but taking them too
seriously is a big mistake and being
self-important is just not a great look
if we all lighten up about our hobbies
and our way of moving then there would
be a lot less aggression online we could
learn from each other and play in each
other's pools we might stop tearing
people down for giving advice we don't
quite agree with because it is all just
advice of course it's really important
not to teach bad form on a movement that
could hurt someone or to manipulate
people's insecurities to sell things
that don't work or haven't been proven
but there is a limit here waiting to
criticize anyone who tries something
different or get something wrong creates
a toxic culture
I'm super lucky that I have such a
positive comment section by the way I
remember once wondering whether it was a
good idea to include a shot of me
climbing a tree in a video I take my
responsibility very seriously and I
never want to encourage someone to do
something that might get them hurt my
rule is that if I wouldn't advise
something to either my sister or my
daughter then I won't talk about it on
YouTube but then I remembered
six-year-olds climb trees no one taught
my daughter the perfect form for leaping
off the sofa more injuries come from ego
lifts and people feeling they need to
prove something if you scale back the
intensity and the weight you have more
room for exploration and fun in your
training when you relax about it that
happens automatically I forget all these
rules that you hear online about what
training should and shouldn't involve
want to take selfies for Instagram
between lifts go for it you do you want
to take 10 minute breaks and read your
phone why not look this isn't school
just be courteous to other people and
we're good so yes I think we all should
train ideally for the sheer Joy of
training and so before I close out I'd
like to just briefly Express that joy
for a moment why I love training for its
own sake
because even as a fitness YouTuber I
spend a lot of my time sitting down
typing when moving through polite
Society I'm encouraged to walk rather
than to run to look presentable and to
go and do the thing I meant to be doing
in the gym or on the field it's
different here I'm encouraged to throw
jump run climb lift pull and push I'm
allowed to actually use my body to its
fullest I'm not caged in anymore this is
when I get to feel the wind through my
hair when I get to explore new areas I
want to get to swing upside down from
Rings this is the closest you get to
being like an action hero pushing a huge
weight off your chest it's the closest
to most of our Lives will come to
looking like a movie
that by the way is partly why I love
making this YouTube channel it lets me
frame training in that way show how we
can do stuff in our real lives that
looks awesome just with the right lens
and a bit of dramatic framing
better yet the more you do this the more
you can do going forwards you increase
your strength unlock new moves and
increase your energy you become more
formidable and you literally increase
your freedom by increasing the number of
options open to you in any given moment
people talk to you differently and you
feel more youthful and energetic I love
reading about training which is also
pretty much my job now even that part
feels like a comic book as you discover
new secrets about the human body new
ways to tap into latent strength and
ability and I love the challenge of
training I love having an obstacle to
overcome when I set for myself and
chipping away at it until I do I love
pushing out one last rep and really
surprising myself with what I can do
the moment when you unlock a new move or
beat your PR is absolutely Priceless I
even love the feeling you get after the
training where your muscles are all kind
of fuzzy and you feel all relaxed and
that gives me permission to relax on the
sofa and to watch gogglebox that evening
it's a topic for another time but I
think we need pillars in our lives to be
well-rounded individuals making Fitness
and productivity everything is missing
the point in my opinion bottom line
training is absolutely awesome don't let
the internet ruin it for you or that
shouty guy at the gym and remember
somewhere inside that shouty guy at the
gym is just a little boy who wants to be
Superman
thanks for watching this one guys I hope
you found it useful and interesting let
me know in the comments down below if
you agree with My Philosophy here am I
too Cavalier with my training or do you
agree that training should be fun and
that we should all kind of relax about
it if you do enjoy training that's fun
and adventurous and has lots of
different aspects to it then you might
enjoy my ebook and training program
super functional training 2.0 that has
just about every form of training you
can imagine most of it is pretty Dynamic
and exciting leave a like if you enjoyed
the video share it around if you like
that helps me out immensely hit
subscribe if you want to see more like
this and either way thank you so much
for watching this video guys I really
appreciate it bye for now